le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
partir à l'étranger c'est peut être la
solution pour prendre un nouveau départ
lorsque l'on est demandeur d'emploi
depuis longtemps le département le cnar
mais le pôle emploi propose réunionnais
un dispositif de mobilité de coopération
dans la zone océan indien
rencontre avec karine qui a tenté
l'expérience en tanzanie et maxine qui
se prépare à partir pour madagascar
[Musique]
toi fabienne tu reçois cette personne
dans son bureau au moment du procès d'
derniers jours de formation pour karine
c'est au tampon au centre international
d'études pédagogiques que la jeune femme
forme ses élèves à la gestion de projet
car dans quelques semaines grâce au
dispositif départemental de mobilité
elles partiront tout pour des missions
d'appui à la francophonie dans la zone
océan indien
c'est un dispositif qui permet à des
personnes réunionnaise qui veulent aller
travailler dans la zone ferroviaire sur
divers types de postes notamment en lien
avec la langue française la promotion la
diffusion la langue française si karine
maîtrise son sujet c'est qu'elle a
travaillé pendant deux ans à l'ambassade
française de tanzanie en tant que chargé
de mission
une aventure humaine et professionnelle
qu'elle n'est pas prête d'oublier ça
c'est venu chercher je sais pas un désir
de découvrir la zone on peut être la
zone océan indien et de me découvrir moi
même franchement d'un point de vue
professionnel
une expérience extrêmement riche et puis
d'un point de vue humain l'expatriation
je pense que c'est toujours riche on se
remet beaucoup en question canton
confronté aux cantons les impliquer dans
la culture des autres on remet en
question sa propre cul sa propre culture
certains aspects sa propre culture
ça permet de prendre du recul
le sari ferme fournisseurs des richesses
des autres ce dispositif proposé par le
département en collaboration avec le
cnar mais le pôle emploi offre à des
personnes éloignées du monde du travail
l'occasion de découvrir l'océan indien
et ses richesses le but aujourd'hui
c'est de permettre à ceux qui sont
jeunes et moins jeunes de pouvoir avoir
quand il n'y a parfois pas la
possibilité d'un emploi sur place de
pouvoir justement ouvrir de nouvelles
expériences comprendre l'océan indien et
dans le cadre du marché futures la
mobilité au sein dia va être une des
mobilités les plus intéressantes pour
que justement il est la possibilité
d'une expérience et la possibilité aussi
de se dire je peux aussi travaillé dans
ces pays très proche de chez nous mais
parfois très éloignés dans ce qu'on
pensait faire de notre vie
né à saint denis une nouvelle génération
va bientôt profiter de cette expérience
dans quelques semaines maxime s'envolera
pour madagascar
sa mission promouvoir la langue
française dans un lycée mais aujourd'hui
c'est elle qui s'initient aux malgaches
la gare saint jean est né non ordinaire
une formation importante pour son
intégration lors de sa mission
ce que j'ai fait de leur donner c'est
des bases déjà deux langues
on écrit en aura surtout pour qu'ils
puissent se débrouiller qui ne soit pas
trop étranger qui ne perdent pas trop de
temps au départ elle même si la plupart
des gens qu'on va rencontrer par le
français je pense qu'un bon échange
c'est que nous aussi on puisse apprendre
aussi leur langue
moi j'y vais aussi pour ça pour
apprendre le malgache pour pouvoir le
parler couramment psychologue de
formation
maxine est sans emploi depuis plusieurs
années
ce dispositif lui offre l'opportunité de
prendre un nouveau départ
on est agent du département on est
rémunéré 1000 euros par mois ce qui est
une fortune là bas ce qui peut paraître
très près ici mais on y va surtout pour
l'aventuré en fin de compte on n'est pas
aussi pour se sortir vue de la condition
de rsa donc on est quand même dans un
monde où le chômage est tellement
important que même être tueur diplômés
va ça aide pas forcément donc là ça peut
être un tremplin un tremplin vers
l'inconnu mais entre les formations et
l'accompagnement financier les futurs
coopérants peuvent partir l'esprit
tranquille
le billet d'avion est pris en charge par
le club le visa est à notre charge
et puis après on a une prime
d'installation quand même qui est mise
en place 600 euros à peu près ce qui est
formidable si tu veux c'est comme
partout sans peur parce que on est
justement soutenu et encadrée et très
bien encadré a diet hâte de commencer de
baigner dans le bain dhr
[Musique]
le dispositif de mobilité océan indien
permet aux réunionnais de valoriser leur
savoir-faire de bénéficier d'une
expérience professionnelle unique et de
découvrir une autre culture
ce dispositif concerne les personnes
bénéficiaires du rsa les coopérants
partent en contrat d'insertion d'une
durée d'un an renouvelable une fois
pendant la mission le salaire et 2030
euros par mois pour plus d'informations
rendez vous sur le site du cnar au
www.slate.fr ou sur le site du
département au www.desjardins.com 7 4
point fr lien social accompagne les
réunionnais pour la mobilité
je suis l'allemand un dessin j'ai 20 ans
je suis ici pour un bts muc en
apprentissage au stif cas et je viens de
saint denis au vauban
je travaille deux une épicerie fine de
qualité et le but de cet apprentissage
c'est d'alterner les deux en fait
ben j'ai voulu quand même tenté avoir
même indépendance et 6
un beau départ papalia toujours soutenu
tous les québécois
mais ma - est un petit peu inquiète déjà
donc c'est ce qui est normal voilà quoi
kate a fait rien à voir le paquet là
c'est franchement les biens ouais c'est
un bilan positif
[Musique]
oh